she don't want to kick it let's do this
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Alan Saki on yesterday I
was at Matt Dillahunty s talk that he
was giving on magic and skepticism in
San Francisco it was a blast
I had a lot of fun learned a lot and
Matt was kind enough to want to come on
the show today
before he leaves back to Austin so it's
very nice of you to come on the show
Matt thanks very much thanks for having
me Matt Dillahunty is the host of the
atheist experience for the last 13 years
he's been doing that since 2005 right
yeah I confused sometimes whether it's
been 13 14 whatever I think it was I
think I took over as host at some point
in 2005 so yeah and that's been rolling
along swimmingly is that about every
month every week it's every week there
were in the early years I probably did
50 shows a year lately I'm not on as
much I'm traveling a lot more and now
there was at one point I was the only
host to number five co-hosts and then we
switched to having two hosts and five
co-hosts and now we have three hosts in
five colors so you know if I'm not
around there's somebody else who can do
it and probably better so
interchangeable I don't know that I
think the more you know difference the
complementary so that you know it's not
just all one note yeah and also the
president of the atheist community of
Austin from 2006 to 2013
yep and that's just changed again
actually ACA had their elections two
weeks ago and we also have a new program
called talk heathen and it's got Eric
and Jamie or the hosts Jamie's now the
new president of the ACA we've changed a
lot of board members and so I've got
really excited because this is kind of
like there's a bunch of us that have
been running it for a dozen or more
years or maybe 20 and now there's a new
generation coming in I'm excited to see
what they're gonna do yeah it's always
interesting to see what young people
especially around
right now 25 ish then even what the 14
year-olds are gonna be talking about
when they become older and they get into
some of the things that you're talking
about on your show on our show here what
exactly civilization gonna be like
that's a lot of what we talk about on
the show how can we build a better world
for everyone moving forward you've been
doing a lot of touring you've been going
on speaking with sam and sam harris
lawrence krauss a little bit of richard
dawkins that's been fun yeah oh yeah
yeah you feel like audiences have been
fairly receptive to you guys teaching
about both atheism but also about ideas
and trying to get people to want to talk
about ways that we can design the future
better oh yeah I think so I mean you
know when we at the big events you
always wonder how much you're just
potentially preaching to the choir that
you know this is the people that show up
at my event are they all my fans the
people that show up at Sam's event are
they all Sam's fans and whatever I one
of the reasons I had fun working with
those guys in particulars because we
don't share exactly the same fan base
although that is a great overlap we do
talks about different things I mean when
we show up it's pretty much weird dinner
then right before the event and we're
like what's on your mind what do you
feel like talking about what do you not
feel like talking about and then the
conversations are just really kind of
spontaneous eye on those things I kind
of sit in a I mean I'm not just there to
interview those guys that was the deal
right of the star I don't just show up
and let me ask you questions I've got
thoughts and things to contribute so
it's and it's kind of a fun dance to
figure out how far do you let something
go you know because I'm kind of steering
and kind of participating in the
conversation and it's it's been great
and and the response has been really
good from
everybody I've spoken to anyway but that
might be a self-selected group it might
be only people who like me who are
telling me how much they liked what we
did it's good that you guys have that
slightly different audiences and then
you're also kind of going a bit on you
know you're at dinner the night before
or even the day of and you're just like
hey what do you guys want to talk about
what do you think's most impactful for
us to talk about to the audience it's
important though I mean I'm happy to do
like a structured debate with the topic
I do that all the time and if I had a
debate scheduled let's say for tonight
that was you know on the resurrection or
morality and humanism or whatever then
I'd be happy to stick on the topic but
also you know I was just noticing on the
news and I've been out of the loop on
everything but there was another school
shooting today in Texas and if I was
doing an event with Sam or Richard
whoever else we could we would almost
certainly bring that up and talk that
talk about that issue it's nice because
you get on-the-spot current events and
there's some really great thoughts from
some of the folks on stage not
necessarily it's not like any of us know
what the absolute solution to this
problem is but rather than just showing
up an earring oh I'm going to give you a
lecture on this subject there's an
actual conversation that takes place and
it can change and then immediately
following whatever we want to talk about
is there's always the audience Q&A which
is always my favorite part of every
event for the magic and skepticism to
her you know I had given lectures on
skepticism before given lectures on
skepticism that included magic before
and had done it more in a close up
environment and I worked this out for
the stage and it's it's a lot of work
and there's you know there's music and
there's a ton of crap to carry around to
all the events and everything and I
genuinely love doing it I've been doing
magic forever but the part of every
evening that I enjoy the most is the Q&A
and it's the most frustrating thing that
can happen worse than not being able to
get a volunteer up on stage is to start
the Q&A and have nobody wanting to ask
one dad to be the first one to ask a
question so you get the first one done
there's
more questions than you can handle but
that's that's the thing I enjoy the most
is let's build the communities let's
have the conversations that they want to
have because quite often honestly a good
chunk of the people that showed up may
not have really cared that much about me
lecturing on skepticism they just wanted
the opportunity to ask questions so
there's a certain aspect of what you're
talking about which can be called flow
that when you get into a sort of
sporadic conversation that's not
structured ahead of time like when you
go on a normally structured television
program that it actually is really nice
to just be able to play and dance with
ideas and thoughts and energies and like
you said that same thing happens with
Q&A it's not scripted people are just
coming up and asking you whatever is on
their mind whatever they want to talk
about and then it keeps you on your feet
and on your toes that's that's that's a
really important aspect of of
conversation in general is having a be
non-scripted be totally flipped a
quantumness
even keel so I want to touch on this a
little bit I think a lot of people that
follow you know this but I think it's a
good story to still communicate so you
were raised Southern Baptist primarily
yeah and then that was like a good 20
plus year portion of your life all of my
life until I was around 30 or so now
that being said you know I walked down
the aisle at a revival at the age of
five and accepted Jesus into my heart
and that I was active in the church
throughout my teen years when as a teen
I joined the Navy and while I still
believed it wasn't like it was a huge
part of my life I was off you know
touring the world with the with the Navy
and then I worked at a tech industry for
a number of years which is why I think
when I lost I lost my job with Dell
around 2000 2001
I actually thought God was punishing me
because I because I had previously been
you know Sunday morning Sunday night
Monday night Wednesday night Thursday
night Saturday you know youth group
mission trips blah blah blah and then I
got to a point where I just believed but
didn't really do anything about it I was
living my life and so I thought you know
God was kind of punishing me
but yeah so where was that moment for
you or those series of moments after
that 2001 to time that you were like I
want to consider atheism skepticism how
did that transition can't happen
that never happened I'd always been a
skeptic I just hadn't applied it to
religion there was nothing in me that
said oh I want to consider atheism what
happened was I thought that God had
punished me and taken away you know the
job the career that I'd worked for and I
thought it was because he had wanted me
to be a preacher which is what a number
of family members and evidently most of
the people in the church that I grew up
in thought as well it's a matter of fact
when I did a debate last year with
Michael Kona some people from the church
that I attended as a teenager came down
there and during the Q&A one of them got
up and said basically we thought you
were going to do great things for the
Lord what happened so I kind of
explained to him what happened but what
actually happened there was I sat down
and said okay god I feel may be a
preacher I'll do it and my roommate that
time was an atheist and we were best
friends still are and I set out to try
to figure out how to convince him
because I thought if you're gonna do
this you're gonna take it seriously you
don't want to get to heaven and have God
say why is this guy who you love like a
brother burning in hell why didn't you
do your job so I set out to to find the
best way to convince him and that's when
I found out that you know a lot of the
things that atheists were saying about
religion we're somewhere accurate some
weren't you can find just some like if
you go look for a list of like Bible
contradictions you'll find that most of
them are not really that impressive and
certainly wouldn't have changed my mind
but what I realized is when I applied
skepticism to my religious beliefs it's
not that I found out my religious
beliefs were wrong it's the found out
that the reasons that I had for
believing
those things were wrong they were they
were insufficient to justify belief and
I had you know there was no choice it's
just oh that one day you're convinced
and then after some studying you're no
longer convinced because the God I
believed in is is unfalsifiable there's
no way for me to prove he doesn't exist
but there's definitely no reason to
think that he does and there are good
reasons to think that if he did exist we
would live in a much much different
world and so yeah just trying to be the
best Christian if it could be is how I
ended up being an atheist so backfired
spectacularly okay so then as you go
through this this this period of time
when you're talking to your roommate and
you're slowly starting to uncover these
this this transition within yourself
more towards the understanding that
maybe atheism is something that and this
is this idea of skepticism something
that I'm starting to apply to even my
religious beliefs and it's making more
sense that I am now maybe a little more
atheist myself and so then that slowly
came out and then you caught yourself as
the host of the Atheist experience so
yeah it was kind of weird my so my
roommate and I actually never had any
conversations about this I was doing all
this prep work to kind of go after him
and instead I kind of found my way out I
remember driving home from work one day
and he was driving and we worked at the
same place and I said you know I think
I'm kind of agnostic now and he goes
cool Wow and they just kept driving but
what ended up happening on is I was
writing for some early museums that like
moment in the car I wonder how we can
get to more moments like that just in
general where people take their ideas
and they go hey I'm gonna openly be
vulnerable and tell you that I'm gonna
put that other idea that I had to decide
and I'm gonna go with this idea moving
forward well it depends though because
I'm sitting in a car with an atheist who
knows that I've been in fundamentalist
Christian my entire life that's not that
vulnerable to say hey I'm leaning more
towards your son what would have been
vulnerable is if I was in the car with
my dad and had said yeah I think I'm
kind of an atheist now which there was a
moment like that later as well but good
point yeah it's I hear from people all
the time who have changed their minds
and are dealing with coming out to
various people or what's the best way to
do this and the best recommendation that
I give I think is to not make any kind
of big deal out of it just be yourself
be honest eventually somebody's gonna
ask you a question you can say yeah I
just I don't think like that anymore I'm
not convinced of that anymore and now
it's not the threatening thing of oh my
gosh I've just discovered you're
completely wrong about everything you
believe about religion and I had to come
tell you right now so that we can fix
you because that's the exact wrong way
to kind of go about it but I was writing
for some easy ins on the web kind of
self-published loose no real editor type
thing but there was a site called
useless knowledge and there were a
number of both theistic writers and some
kind of pseudo-scientific whoo peddlers
on there and so it was really easy for
me to just start writing rebuttals
because having been a skeptic for ages
when I when I would see these people
talk about the the Indian God men who
live only they don't eat nothing and
they live only on prana from the Sun and
everything else then I can start talking
about how we test those things and then
there was another person on there who
wrote under a pseudonym and would
basically pull a passage out of the
Bible and write a sermon and as kind of
a fun exercise I would take the exact
same passage and go through it in a much
more detail to show how you could
interpret that passage in other ways as
well
and whether or not his particular
preferred interpretation even fit with
does it fit with classical
interpretations has he bothered to study
you know the Greek Hebrew Aramaic does
he understand what this meant at the
time probably for the author what the
author's original intent might have been
is he cherry-picking kind of modern
usages of terms you know and among the
different the thousand different
Christian denominations out there how
much portion of them agree with what
he's saying are there other ways to
interpret it and that was kind of fun it
was it was a way to to teach people
something that I'd learned which was you
know that I grew up with this you know
this one particular fairly rigid strict
rather common understanding of Scripture
and there were people who were saying
hang on a minute that might not say what
you think it says and it doesn't matter
which one of them were correct it may be
that I was mostly correct you know when
I was a Southern Baptist it may be the
people who objected here Moses correct
the the more interesting point for me is
that there's no way to tell who's
correct and if there were a God who was
conveying information had an important
message to convey to people there's no
way any reasonably intelligent being let
alone the wisest being ever would ever
choose to communicate in text languages
that died and change if you go read
Shakespeare modern audiences can't
understand the bulk of what Shakespeare
wrote that's still English just a few
hundred years ago what on earth makes
you think you're gonna understand
nuances in dead languages and languages
of dramatically change in thousands of
years this is a perfect segue into your
communication of the importance of
secular morality versus religious
morality you've been teaching about how
secular morality is dynamic about how
it's able to be changed and that that's
that's a great thing to be able to put
the idea to the side and move forward
with a new one that's better
versus religious morality which is baked
into this text you were just describing
with Shakespeare swell I mean we've
progressed so much to where a lot of
these things even looking back at our
Constitution from 240 years ago were
like there's probably some things that
we could do to make this better moving
forward and so I'm hope your segue yeah
how sad would it be to figure to think
that oh you know two hundred and forty
years ago somebody cracked it and it
came up with a perfect thing and now
we're just you know done that's I mean
it's nice we live in a dynamic universe
and our views of that should change as
well now at the end of the day depending
on how something is framed there may in
fact be a rigid single correct moral
answer to a particular situation I'm a
big advocate for situational ethics but
grounded in in general principles that
serve as basic rules that can have
exceptions and that can be changed if we
find out that one of the premises we
have has been flawed so you can
construct a moral system off something
as simple as life is generally
preferable to death and you have to
acknowledge right off the bat that
that's a general rule because when you
start adding the other things you'll
realize that I might find myself in a
situation where I'm a terminal patient
and constant pain and it may be the case
the death of Jeff Jenna is becomes
preferable to life for me in that
scenario but that doesn't change the
fact that by and large what we're
concerned about is life and a good life
we're more concerned about thriving than
merely surviving we're concerned about
being able to hold people accountable
for their actions irrespective of
whether you believe there's free will or
not you know what we know for certain or
as close to certain as we can we don't
know anything for certain you called a
maximal certainty last night yeah it's
and it's kind of difficult to dig into
and I'm not going to start right now but
the one things one of the things we can
be confident and assuming I'm not you
know the only brain in your figment of
my imagination is that
you and I no matter where we're
different are living beings and it's in
our best interest to continue living as
much as possible yeah it's it frustrates
me when the one of the more common
responses or challenges is why should we
care about well-being I mean that's come
up over and over again
and it's a legitimate question it's just
I don't think it's remotely that
difficult nothing I'm not saying and
nobody else that I'm aware of is saying
that the universe has some prescriptive
notion to require us to care about
well-being but we do because we even if
you want to being completely selfish
about it I care about what's in my best
interest it's in my best interest as far
as I can tell to keep living so you come
up with these foundations and if you
find out that life is actually worse
given a given a certain principle I mean
you don't have to start with these you
could start with death is preferable to
life and then you try and live for a
while that way and all of a sudden you
discover hang on a minute everybody's
dying off yeah that's not in our
interest of our well-being there are
people who might claim that they don't
care about well-being you know why
should I care about well-being well I
can give you reasons why you should I
I think it's clear that you do otherwise
I don't think we'd be having this
conversation
but there's nothing that says you have
to and this is actually where I think
religious ideas have kind of poisoned
how we think about certain things in
particular morality and death because it
seems that people are like I need some
prescriptive authority to tell me you
must care about this and they don't seem
capable of recognizing that not only do
they already care about that but they
would care about that thing whether or
not there was somebody saying that they
should and and on the death front to dig
in on a whole other subject but if I
think that if we taught people that
death as far as we can tell is an
inevitable consequence of life it would
fundamentally change how we viewed life
and people are in religious traditions
are very fond of this notion of an
afterlife of when I die it's not over
and I get to go somewhere and I get why
that's appealing yeah but what it does
is it turns absolutely everything you
know about existence everything's ever
happened in your life everything's ever
happened in anybody else's life every
moment of joy every good meal every
friendship every bit of knowledge that
you've learned every joyous moment every
interaction with somebody else
turns all of that into nothing because
everything is just a place to wipe your
feet before the real life starts because
once you die you get to go on to another
life that lasts forever so if we're in
that life let's say for five billion
years how valuable is the 75 to 100
years that you had in this life free of
Sam it's nothing and and that five
billion years is also nothing in
comparison to eternity it devalues
everything wonderful about this life
when this is in fact the only thing we
know we're gonna get and so I just
prefer to view it as if there is an
afterlife it's a bonus it's a bonus that
I don't seem to be able to do anything
about and I'd like to live as long as I
can in this life because so far as I can
tell this is the only place where I
learned something there's only place
where I have experiences and I without
well I don't want to go down another
rabbit hole but I actually think the
notion of the soul is the single most
dead concept in all of theology okay
let's unpack what you just said a little
more and then we'll kind of continue
going down skepticism because sure right
now we're talking about the sort of this
thus both secular morality and the
importance of being able to change your
mind and and also be able to change as
you get more data be able to change what
your belief systems are as well as the
the notion of maybe skepticism around
Eve
and were like maximal confidence with
something you were talking about maximal
certainty last night I thought that was
really interesting so with something
like life being better than death
maximal certainty we could call that
almost always maximal certainty and then
if you're terminally ill on your
deathbed and it's better to die then
that's what a moment when death is
better than life so there's only noise I
wouldn't put that I actually wouldn't
put that an on par with maximal
certainty a music so when I but the
earth orbiting the star that would be
maximal certainty I'm not even sure that
would qualify what qualifies as a
maximal certainty the math okay okay all
of the things that people would normally
say we could be absolutely certain about
I'm not convinced that you can have
absolute certainty because of
philosophical issues related to the
problem of our salep system you know is
the reality I experienced the ultimate
reality or whatever else and I used to
say my math can't be absolute certainty
is because of solids is amiss only I
exist because I know I exist and that's
it I can't actually prove that anybody
else exists and then the other potential
society Gnaeus arguments are we could be
the brain-in-a-vat
we this is not based reality so because
of that the math is not an actual
absolute certainty that's right now sir
do you know you I'm not convinced that
you can have absolute certainty about
anything because of the simulation and
sobs as an argument no because because
you everything about logical reasoning
is founded on identity non-contradiction
and excluded middle that threefold
foundation but you can't prove those
things are absolute and true that they
couldn't change somewhere else it seems
that they can't it seems absurd to think
they can't but you're now you're using
reasoning to affirm reasoning
and so just in the sense of the model
can't be completed and of itself
you can't get to absolute certainty but
what you can do is get to maximum
certainty which is beginning with the
laws of identity and non contradiction
excluded middle I can be maximally
certain about those and I can be
maximally certain about anything that is
deductively arrived from those
foundations which would be things like
mathematics as soon as you get outside
of direct deductive arguments from the
foundations of reason to a conclusion or
an understanding things like math when
you get to inference or an inductive
arguments now sudden you've decreased
beyond even maximal certainty it could
be you can be incredibly confident about
it but for me it's not a big deal an
individual's expressed confidence level
and an idea is largely irrelevant to me
because we act in accordance with our
beliefs no matter how confident we are
about them if I'm only 51 percent
convinced that X is true I'm still going
to act as if X is true it's not doesn't
mean that I'm you know the if somebody
expresses a confidence level all they're
doing is telling me they really really
really believe it but if all you need to
do to inform your actions is just
believe it no matter how confident you
are then it's the beliefs that matter
because that's what dictate what kind of
actions you're going to take let's talk
about this existential skepticism again
or this knowledge skepticism I want to
see if we can maybe pin pin pin it down
with the foundational layer that so that
we can build on top of it so because
there's not a fully absolute certain
understanding of existence therefore we
can't have an absolute certainty
no because you cannot offer a foundation
for reason you can't be absolutely
certain okay
existence is irrelevant offer a
foundation for reason okay but
mathematics gives us close to that
foundation now mathematics is derived
from the foundations of reason okay okay
all right so okay I feel like I'm
understanding it a little bit better and
I and I'll I'll definitely end up
learning more about this in practicing
these principles more that the that the
fountain the foundation of reason II
there's no absolute certainty for
foundation of reason therefore there's
no absolute certainties yes because the
conclusions you draw from your toolkit
cannot be more accurate than the toolkit
can be so like if I have a yardstick or
well that's not yardstick that's a ruler
yeah
and it's divided up into sixteenths of
an inch I can never be more of accurate
in any measurement that I make from that
than 1/16 of an inch now that's not
entirely true because you can I don't
get off on too much today you pull out a
piece of paper you could do have
sixteenths of an inch is you could draw
diagonals and then mathematically you
can get gradually more precise but just
in as a general rule if I'm holding it
up here I can't get you more accurate
than 1/16 minute okay so then so then a
good way maybe as an analogy to
understand it then is that we're just
monkeys on this rock trying to build a
toolkit and our toolkit can't actually
be an absolute certainty toolkit yeah
except that it's not that reason is
something that we've invented it's
something that we've kind of discovered
so the laws of identity
non-contradiction it's good at middle
are often described as for me the
easiest way to look at it is with a
simple Venn diagram where you have one
circle
and identity is whatever is in the
circle is in the circle whatever is not
in the circle is not in the sir okay
no actually identity is whatever's in
the circles in the circle yep
non-contradiction
is this idea that nothing can be both in
the circle and not in the circle okay
and then the law of excluded middle is
everything is either
in the circle or not in the circle okay
so it doesn't matter what category you
put like you could say that this is
literally versions of the letter A or
things in the circle and then pineapple
which isn't even the same category would
be something that's not in that circle
because this circle is the definition
that is a foundation for all reason it's
it's what we use to identify things and
categorize them it's how we know that no
matter what whether we use no matter
what numerals were using the concept of
one plus one equals two for particular
definitions of one and two and equals
and plus is consistent it's directly
derived from those things so however
continentally sir yes and maximally
certain could actually be absolute it's
just that we have no way to confirm that
this is you know that we are in fact
absolutely certain about this so I use
maximally certain as a way of pointing
out that I don't see a path to absolute
certainty I'm open to somebody
demonstrating that and but reason is the
thing that we can be most certain about
and anything directly derived from
reason would be co-equal to that so like
mathematics is it is reason done with
quantities okay and so we can be
maximally certain about that a planet
orbiting is Sun a star is probably way
way up there but I wouldn't put it as
maximally certain I would put it as
close to maximum oh yeah and it's not
even that important to me to categorize
how confident I am when I talk about
this I talk about knowledge being a
subset of belief
here's all the things I believe and some
subset of those things I claim to know
and this is where we get into
epistemology how do you know what you
know what qualifies as knowledge is it
justified true belief is it you know
yeah but at the end of the day for me
the beliefs are what matters because
that's why we act and if you put
something in this knowledge category my
definition of knowledge in this sense is
a belief that is held to such a high
degree of confidence it would be
worldview altering to discover that it
was wrong so it would be fundamentally
worldview altering for me to discover
that we are not on a planet that orbits
the Sun yep
but I wouldn't say I'm maximally certain
maximally certain is kind of a it's a
way of pointing out that there are
things that we are we may or may not be
absolutely certain of even though we
can't demonstrate the path to certainty
so okay this is a good segue into the
next area of topic conversation because
the idea of building a society or
designing the future of society based on
some sort of maximal certainties seems
to be a good idea well the the types of
things we can be maximally certain about
from what I'm talking about I don't know
how you'd build the science a society on
math
the types of things that that I think
about what I'm talking about building a
society are not so much mere facts or
even direct reasoning from those things
it's there are aspects of Building
Society that are clearly in our best
interest when we talk about well-being
and thriving that have nothing to do
with things that we could be maximally
certain about give me some examples
sure well one of the one of the key
things to recognizes is a notion of
empathy we might also have ideas about
well-being in best interest that are the
current best approximations of what
helps us but they don't approach
mathematics they don't even approach the
confidence level I have that the Earth
orbits the Sun they can be dramatically
wrong it's just that they seem at the
moment for example I begin with value
foundations of individual autonomy that
I am the arbiter of what happens to my
life and I give up some of those things
because I live in a cooperative society
and I recognize that there's value in me
limiting my freedoms because I need in
order for my freedoms to protect that I
have to protect the freedoms of others
and so if I want to Ford somebody else
similar freedoms that automatically
diminishes both of our freedoms which is
fine and necessary yeah you're right to
swing your fist ends at my nose or
actually slightly before my nose there's
nothing about that that is because you
don't want them to do the same thing or
for you to do the same thing of them
it's the Golden Rule treat others the
way you want to be treated the golden
rule is a mess especially the one that
Jesus used because it hid the version
that he supposedly used is do unto
others as you would have them do unto
you which means I should treat you the
way I want to be treated but the thing
is what if I like brutal honesty and you
don't yeah yeah it's something much
better would be that I should treat you
the way you want to be treated
unless that comes in convoy
with other values sooo there's this
complicated mesh there because if you
want to be you know beaten with a belt
I'm not gonna do that because that has
an impact on my psyche as well I'm just
not going to go take Annabelle to you or
just so everyone knows Matt Dillahunty
is into BDSM yeah it's yeah hooray but
no we're talking about how to build a
society you know that it's not like we
approach I think that science I agree
with Sam that science has things to tell
us about well-being and things to tell
us about how to correct things and so
the notions of maximal certainty really
I mean it don't enter into it other than
you're always going to use reasoning I
really enjoyed what you said there which
was that we both have were our own
ultimate arbiters we have our own
ultimate freedom until this point of me
kind of maybe swinging my fist or or or
putting your health or wellness at risk
at that time because then my freedom
ends there because I do not want to put
you in a state of being injured and I
freedom ends there and it's ultimately
better for us to cooperate in that sense
of our freedoms ending at that point of
committing violent acts on to each other
therefore we both prosper better in that
sense yeah I mean that's kind of an
extreme example you you get to less
extreme examples if you kind of analyze
it okay I've got my body produces waste
I have to do something to get rid of
that waste but that doesn't mean I can
just get rid of the waste on your
property or sauce or whatever so now
that gets us to okay how we're gonna do
what again how we're gonna deal with
waste disposal both bodily waste and
just the trash oh dude this thing
impacts everybody it's recognizing that
we begin with full freedom full autonomy
nobody gets to tell me what to do with
my life and then as we participate in a
society we recognize that there are
benefits that we get from being in
society you can look at it from a game
theory perspective but at the end of the
day
I don't have the time or the expertise
to both be a doctor and build roads and
do the sanitation services ref and all
these other things and so there's a
benefit to being in the community you
had along with that comes some sacrifice
of your autonomy that you can't just
play your stereo at max volume at 2:00
in the morning when people are sleeping
you probably shouldn't do it at 2:00 in
the afternoon when the people who work
nights are sleeping maybe we should just
have some noise ordinances but there are
complex issues of okay we're all here
how much do I owe the other people in
society how much of my money you know I
get into arguments all the time with
people on me in the extreme libertarian
side who want to say that taxation is
theft taxation is theft it's and it's
violent death because they're
threatening to lock me up and I I
understand what they're saying but you
don't want to go pave your own roads
maybe you don't want
well the libertarian ocean doesn't
doesn't wear nice officer to privately
you'd like those things to continue
being a public good yeah but also this
is a lot that I find I find within some
of the notions libertarianism the the
foundational thing is basically I got
mine screw you if you can't get yours
and I understand that but I don't think
it benefits in build society I don't
think the free market system is going to
take care of everything I don't think
it's gonna take care of charity I don't
think it's gonna take care of the age of
the infirmary or these other things I'm
you know despite however many people
might object I'm a fan of socialized
medicine but I'm not a fan of
socializing everything yeah you said
empathy was one of these values that you
had that you know of your desire to
build a better world and I totally agree
with that and a lot of people that watch
our program do believe that looking out
for our fellow man and a woman in that
sense actually ends up building a better
world together because we're building a
stronger a tighter social fabric that
people can be raised up into and a lot
of kind of what is being discussed right
now with this whole like pick yourself
up and go and forth into the world
there's a little bit of that's that's
very true it's important do that but at
the same time just look at the zip code
literature there are certain places
where it is much much more difficult to
pick yourself up and go and forth into
the world so there's a there's also a
cycle that can occur where you can get
to a point where like I could be so
despondent and out of touch that it is
actually impossible there's no action I
could take that could ever lift myself
up but you could take an action that
could get me back up to the point where
I could take off from there yeah it's
there is an aspect of empathy to all of
this but I've also pointed out that I
think it's fair you can build a robust
moral fabric that builds a strong
Society and have it based only in
selfishness
because let's say all I care about is me
I still have to share space with you
so it's in my best interest to make sure
that if I want to keep my stuff I
encourage a society that doesn't allow
stuff to be stolen
yeah or discourage that that if I'd
rather not be stabbed or murdered that I
work to build a society that protects it
you can do it all for you I would like
to be as wealthy as possible one of
those important concepts and I'm I'm
saying that as a possibility I really
don't care that much about how wealthy I
am but one of the most important
concepts people can Grasse a part grasp
apart from you know the some of the
foundations we've already talked about
is John Rawls veil of ignorance and that
is design the sort of society you want
to live in not knowing who you will be
in that society mm-hmm it's there's a
number different ways to portray it but
if you have six kids sitting around a
birthday cake and you want things to be
fair then you give one of them knife and
they cut the cake knowing that they get
to pick last all of a sudden that cake
gets divided a lot more fairly yeah and
if you design a system not knowing who
you're gonna be that helps remove the
biases that we can't always remove which
is okay do we allow slavery in our
society well considering I could come
into the society as a slave owner or as
a slave I'm gonna say no yeah I'd rather
not be that that gets rid of the broad
in that ways yeah that's good so design
civilization with the intention of not
knowing who you're gonna be in that
designed world okay so that those are
really good ones should slavery exist no
because I could be either the slave or
the slave owner so I don't want to
that's that's that's really good but
notice that it doesn't get you to the it
doesn't get you to a dull gray
everyone's the same because I well I
have a huge problem with massive income
disparity I'm fine
and actually encouraged by the idea that
there are going to be some people who
are going to be better
than others because that can motivate
people to do things to discover things
to change the world
so it's not a dull girl towards these
goals than other people want to work yes
I'm make a decent living you know I grew
up in a relatively moderate lower lower
middle class income family and I do okay
now but I don't make millions but I
don't begrudge people who do make
millions on the other hand I do a
problem with the notion that people have
billions and billions of dollars because
it there's an excess there that is
problematic considering excessive
poverty just on the walk over here there
were countless homeless people out on
the street and I know that we're doing
what we can to help them I would like
for there to be a gap that's more like
this than like this because there's
still room for improvement and growth
and encouragement there when you when
the gap gets to here I think the people
at the top have no motivation to
contribute and the people at the bottom
have neither the motivation or the means
to contribute yes you're nailing it one
of the questions we asked on the show
very often is what do we do about the
wealth inequality gap because right now
a trending conversational point is
Pinker's argument everyone at the bottom
is slowly coming up great that's true
but the people at the very top are
getting way richer way faster now with
the technology age like you just
described the gap is now like this and
it would potentially be better because
now the funneling of resources down here
looks disgusting trying to figure out
how to funnel resources down there and
uplift people that just are really it's
really difficult for them mentally
physically to do things in the world not
just the ones that you can give a
computer to and they'll decide to
program and get out of poverty and then
there's the what would society look like
if that gap was brought to let's say
both ends move up at the same time so
and move up at same time and then the
gaps only like that yeah then then I
think we could have enough movement like
you said there where people are still
excited about innovating and bringing
things up but there's a basic level of
water food clean air shelter these basic
physiological needs that are at least
taken care of in people and then then
enable them to be creative problem
solvers in the world okay I'm glad that
you brought that up that is something
that we talk about all the time on the
show and you brought up a really good
point there now III want to I want to
hear your thoughts about this as well
and I got a couple couple more ones on
the way out but this one too you you you
you're very adamant about being okay
with saying I don't know I am too we
talked about that gonna show a lot it's
so important to be able to say I don't
know that's kind of another thing we're
time i vulnerability earlier it is a
very vulnerable thing when you're on
stage or on live show or wherever you
are to just be like hey it's totally
okay I don't I don't know
I'm let's let's have a conversation
about how we can maybe make it better
well why why do you have that as such a
powerful influence in your life well I
think I remember as a kid I think
everybody's kind of had this experience
where they were in school and they were
asked a question they didn't know and
all of a sudden was terrifying
and in some cases it may be may just be
the fact that you didn't do the reading
and you didn't do the homework and so
you're worried about you know I saying I
don't know and the teachers gonna you
should know because I was in the reading
and you didn't do it but what what we've
done with that is we've kind of
instilled this fear that if somebody
asks you something you should know and
if you don't that means that there's
something wrong with you and so I'd like
to see us start teaching kids that in
some situations in fact in most
situations not only is it okay to say I
don't know but it may be the right
answer may be the case that none of us
know yeah and what's frustrating is that
in order to avoid being faced facing the
consequences of not knowing people will
not just lie not just act as if they
know but actually convince themselves
that they know when on some level
they're recognized that they do that
they don't yeah
you take they go to the biggest
philosophical questions why is there
something instead of nothing I have no
idea it's just the way it is I'm not
even sure this is a sensible question
I'm sure this is a why question it may
be that there's no other option other
than that there's something because and
nothing couldn't exist because then it
would be something would have some
properties if it existed so and nothing
clearly doesn't exist and maybe this is
a problem with the language we use maybe
there's a problem with the concept but
to say I don't know why there's
something and said nothing
doesn't mean that I'm monument ignorant
because I don't think anybody knows yeah
but I know a lot of people who pretend
that they know and I know a lot of
people sees that they can't actually
test and finalize and give you a valid
final objective answer on yeah this is
you know why I talked about religions
potentially doing harm with regard to
morality and death there are big
concerns that we have about life what's
it all about why am I here why is there
something rather nothing what is what is
the purpose of life and religions have
offered people answers
to those questions that aren't actually
explanations and that aren't actually
demonstrable they're just pacifiers they
are we don't want you to be
uncomfortable about meaning and purpose
in life so we're gonna tell you this and
I find it curious I speak at a lot of
universities with student groups over
the years I worked with the secular
Student Alliance on their speaker's
bureau and I have yet to meet a student
I'm sure there's one out there I don't
hyperbole will destroy the world was a
talk I gave but I loved the title of and
I don't try not to exaggerate but I
don't think I've ever met a student who
would genuinely be happy if either their
parents or the government told them what
their career was going to be oh yeah you
know you go to university you may not
necessarily know yourself but if
somebody just said you're gonna be a
doctor you're gonna be a janitor you're
gonna be this you're gonna be that and
here's your path and you have to do your
forces people would revolt they would
their there is nothing about that that
seems appealing to the overwhelming
majority of people because they want to
be the masters of their own destiny even
if they don't have the first clue what
that destiny is and yet when we talk
about the bigger issue of what's the
meaning and purpose to life they seem
incredibly happy with the notion that
there is some being who has already
knows your destiny and is giving you
that so in a situation where we would
revolt in any other circumstance there
are people who are happy with it and I
think it has to do with it being in
slightly different categories you know
you're going to have some kind of job
some kind of future in the world and you
aren't sure what it is you're not
necessarily sure what your skillset is
or what you find what you're passionate
about or what's likely to give you a
sustainable life this sort of income
that where you can you know have a place
and a family and and the things that you
feel like you're supposed to do but you
know it's going to happen when we talk
about this broader meaning
to life it's okay it's understandable
that people accept God has a meaning and
purpose for your life even if they don't
actually say what it is because I think
on some level we recognize that it's
different from life this isn't anything
that you can have any sort of confidence
about it's just oh that's nice God wants
me to live a happy life and he's got my
back when things go wrong or the meaning
and purpose of my life is to to live a
life that is as christ-like as I can be
or to further the will of Allah because
purpose can change over time it can be
dynamic rather than static but the
religious ones don't that's why we were
talking about the importance of secular
morality into secular thought in general
secular meaning secular purpose my life
has whatever meaning and purpose I give
it yep yep so okay so now as a as a as a
fundamental building block for firm for
maximal certainty this seems like a
question I was trying to talk to you
about a little bit last night is there
at the parent kind of making the
decision to have a child and having a
child into the world and birthing that
child it's it's it's it's all of
society's responsibility to build a
really strong society for that child but
also it's do direct responsibility of
that parent right to have that child be
a finding their meaning and purpose in
life but also of that child to find
their own meaning and purpose but it's a
responsibility of that parent to provide
that child with some sort of a
foundational of play and understanding
and care yeah I mean if you assume the
responsibility of basically it so
children aren't property you are
essentially a steward and if you assume
the responsibility doing that then you
have a moral obligation to do the best
you can to give them the toolset that
they need to go on and live their life
as adults and pass this on further
what's in that tool set that's that's
the question I'll start
I think I think the bare minimum that we
should expect is for parents to make
sure that childrens are as healthy and
educated as they can reasonably be
healthy and educated okay and then so
then for example with with things like
high fructose corn syrups or coca-cola
or all these different types of things
that children can sometimes get lashed
into on the health side of things around
the education side of things children
can spend a lot of their time playing
these like candy crush games or fruit
ninja games maybe rather than watching a
video explaining something about physics
or something about math or morality or
or emotion or whatever these other
aspects of life are so where do you kind
of put the line on on on kids having
more access to healthier foods or having
more access to educational content
that's more meaningful or purpose well
so when I say healthy I'm talking about
not not just physical health but mental
health as well and I don't I mean okay
if all you did was play video games
there may in there being problem with
that or you could be come the next
billionaire game creator and have a
wonderful life I think part of it is
about access but to the to the
information but you don't want to
disregard in any way the passions that
children have as a matter of fact so I
don't think everybody needs to go to
college I'm not even convinced everybody
needs to go to a trade school and it's
not just because oh the world needs
garbage collectors too that's not
remotely that what I'm talking about
what I'm saying is that we've developed
a society particularly in the West based
on capitalism rooted in money that is
all about let me see what the best
career I can get to get me the money to
do this that is often a really good way
to live a healthy happy life but it's
not the only way
be life I I'm doing I could make a lot
more money if I wasn't travelling around
the world you know giving lectures on
skepticism and humanism and matter of
fact him I could make tons of money if I
went back to Christianity and started
touring churches and taking up offerings
of talking about how you know if I lost
all my ethics and trying to do that way
but I'm having it I'm living a happy
life because I'm doing the things that I
enjoy
I don't need billions of dollars to make
me happy I need enough to cover my basic
needs to make sure that I'm don't wind
up destitute and the rest of the time I
get to spend enjoying my life and it
happens to be the case that the things
that I enjoy most out of life tend to
also benefit others I'm learning more
about the world all the time and sharing
what I learned I'm having conversations
with people who are asking me questions
that I don't know and I'm going and
studying to see what I can find out
about it and if I find an answer I can
get back with that person and get back
with others and if I don't I can
continue pointing out that as far as I
know I don't know so and I don't mean to
just pick on the point of kid singer I'm
playing candy crush I think it's
important to recognize that you can do
anything to access you can be a social
justice activist to the point where it
destroys your life and where you're not
actually doing good where you're usually
yelling at everything that's gone wrong
and this is a Chicken Little the sky is
falling everything is the worst thing
ever is there's a balance is there some
sort of a foundational foundation of
maximal certainties that maybe parents
should instill into kids no well I mean
in teaching them about reason and math
and the things that we can be maximally
certain yeah it's important okay
instilling in them fostering empathy
fostering curiosity
yeah the desire to discover and learn
about the world was a great ones yeah
empathy that's the reason yeah okay
that's that's that's good that's good
all right what are your thoughts about
this this is this kind of pairs together
with the globalization wealth inequality
question as we have so much wealth be
concentrating
so few people were where do we move
forward with nationalism versus
collectivism how do we progress forward
as a planet through our borders US China
Russia specially with AI and
biotechnology and space colonization
cryptocurrencies all these different
types of things that are slowly
manifesting and impacting our planet how
do we work together moving forward what
are what are your thoughts about that I
have no idea i I can't remotely pretend
to have a solution I think that I would
like to think that the sorts of things
I'm advocating all work together for
that that if we scepticism I'm a skeptic
I'm a humanist I'm an atheist and the
Atheist is the least important part of
that skepticism is about how I go about
determining the facts about reality what
is believable what is it I know of
nothing better than that for building a
model of reality humanism is essentially
the recognition that this isn't pairs
together with epistemology quite well
it's yes it is it is essentially a
description of an epistemological method
method yeah or in the philosophical
sense an ideal I want to believe as many
true things and as few false things as
possible which is what I had on a
t-shirt my wife was actually wearing
that shirt last night when she sent me a
picture so skepticism is about
understanding the world it has nothing
about it that relate that is
specifically a values based system
humanism though is my value-based system
and that is founded on this notion that
essentially as far as I can tell I got
one life if I get more fine if somebody
demonstrates that there's another so I
have an obligation to live a life that
is productive that is cooperative
because all of those things benefit me
and they benefit others and but the goal
of humanism is not say this is what life
should be the goal of humanism
essentially is to say as far as we can
tell we're here
our own cooperating and we are going to
work together including revising our
based principles and values to build a
better world where people are not merely
surviving but are thriving as best they
can where you would be proud to bring in
the next generation of humans yeah not
knowing whether they're going to be born
into the lowest tier of wealth or
societal health or physical health or
the highest because we've squashed that
inequality I don't know what the what
the precise path is I am I've
acknowledged many many times that there
are some areas where I am woefully
ignorant
and and broader social political ideas
you know we not to get into like the
israeli-palestinian conflict but I'm not
pro-israel which means I'm not
anti-israel basically I don't know
enough about it to even pretend like I
know what a solution would be
I'm just actively working to make sure
that we promote as much skepticism and
humanism as possible because I think
that if skepticism humanism were to take
root in that area the conflict would go
away I this is I have to talk about this
is perfect actually the the notion of
skepticism being this epistemological
method of understanding the and wanting
to be as many of the true things as
possible and as a little of the false
things of any none of the false things
as possible and then humanism this this
wanting to cooperate and design the
world for the future where no matter
who's born into it they're living a good
a good life okay those are amazing
principles and I think that we totally
vibe and resonate on those and I think a
lot of people will from watching the
show take those away as really important
now I just want to bring this into kind
of today's world as you were just
describing it because this is one point
that I really wanted to get to at the
end was that
when you take anything that you hear and
see as an anecdote no matter who it even
comes from really even if it's coming
from you or coming from me towards one
another that we first start with a
skeptical mindset about it that we're
going to have to go and validate what
that person said and this is especially
true when people say that oh
cryptocurrencies are currently using
half a percent of all of the world's
energy and then I heard that last night
and so immediately I thought to myself
okay I'll pocket that as a possibility
and I'm gonna go and learn more about it
and see if it's actually true and but
that that understanding of things rather
than just reading it or hearing it and
going forth with it as a complete truth
there's something that you think and I
think what could you agree is really
important to do sure especially in
today's like news cycles and craziness
okay I think we covered pretty much
everything that when we needed to cover
in the conversation I wanna I want to
ask you what do you think's the most
beautiful thing in the world
man there's so many glib answers on
tempted to give I don't think there is a
most beautiful thing there are a number
of things that I'm gonna find more
beautiful and more wonderful depending
on the day and the mood and everything
like laughter I would want to put high
up on the list I love you know I'm not a
stand-up comedian but I I include a
number of lines both in the shows and on
you know everywhere that get a laugh and
there's a few things that feel better
than somebody appreciating a clever bit
of humor but is it the laugh that I'm
appreciating or is it the sort of
intelligence is that the thing that's
actually beautiful I love I don't find
myself I love art but I mean it's not
like I'm often moved by art like I've
been to a number of art museums on this
tour and actually the one piece of art
that impact would be probably more than
any other one had wasn't in an art
museum it was something that was for
sale in a Black History Museum and it
was a painting by a gentleman I
forgotten the name I've got a picture of
it but it's called stranger fruit and
strange fruit was a song that
essentially was lamenting lynchings of
african-americans in the south and and
it would be the african-americans would
be the strange fruit hanging from the
trees it was this really kind of morbid
political statement and this one was
called stranger fruit and had a bunch of
African Americans standing at the base
of a tree with white folks hanging
having been lynched and I know that
there are people who would see that who
would be like oh my gosh they're calling
for the destruction but it was a it was
a brilliant political statement about
changing your perspective of the world
and and how certain things would impact
you is no piece of art I don't think
I've ever reviewed a piece of art that
kind of hit harder than that I'm there
there are bits of music that are some of
my favorite things ever but I think all
of those things I think the laughter I
think the art and the music all boiled
down to a particular notion of
intelligence and it's not about an IQ
score and it's not about how much you
know it is about the application of
inquiry and creativeness that is
essentially human that is is the
foundation under all of those and so I
think I'd have to say that that's
probably the most beautiful thing in
querying creativity yeah I really love
asking people that question especially
your answer was great maybe give us a
quick thought on what your I'd give us a
Cliff Notes version of what are your
current thoughts about like what's going
on with the intellectual dark web yeah
yeah I know all this emotional dark web
stuff came up while I was touring I
haven't read much about it but I find it
really kind of baffling I'm definitely
glad I didn't make the list considering
I know quite a few of the people on the
list to me it doesn't make any sense
first of all I don't think we need a
label for this I don't think it's I
don't think it's a web thing or a dark
web thing all right this is this is kind
of marketing and it seems absurd for me
to see sam harris and ben shapiro on the
same list
the one thing that essentially we're
talking about the only thing i can find
that all of those individuals seem to
care about is protection of free speech
and inquiry
and a real distrust of a portion of the
left that whether they're called
regressive left or whatever else that
are without a doubt the chicken little
reactionary overrated so it's all
hyperbole my friend Seth has labeled
them the outrage brigade and that they
engage in oh my gosh how did you phrase
it it was so recreational outrage that
that they're more concerned about the
outrage than they are the things they
are outraged about this doesn't apply to
everybody on the left it was kind of
frustrating for me because Sam had an
interaction with Ezra Klein where I
think they were talking past each other
anybody who thinks that Sam's a racist I
I can't see that I also don't put him
out with the right but after that
interaction he was there was no
charitable listening there was he got
frustrated and he said that he's done
with the left I think that was a mistake
because like two days later Ben Shapiro
lumped him in with the alt-right and put
him in Jordan Peterson some others in in
the same bucket I'm not done with the
left I'm Way out on the left
I'm just not so far out on the left that
I'm gonna be hyperbolic about stuff I'm
still gonna be advocating for social
justice issues I'm still a free speech
advocate I just I I was called a Nazi
sympathizer because I suggested that
it's not a good idea to run around
punching people on the street for saying
things that are awful you can point out
that they're awful yeah and you can sit
down on stage with people you vehemently
disagree with and get them to expose
themselves get them to expose the flaws
in their thinking and to have your flaws
exposed you know and I think that
there's a fear from some that if they
engaged in that the hyperbolic flaws and
their thinking would be exposed steel
man conversation and reason yeah yeah
together so I think they entered I think
the intellectual darkweb thing I think
it'll probably go away pretty quickly
especially since the people that are in
there don't really agree on all that
much
I don't think that we needed as a label
but I Joe when I read the two articles
that I read on it I was just like
whatever this is almost to the point the
same people that I can I kind of dismiss
at the extremes of both the left and the
right I think they're doing the same
thing like there's gonna be an extreme
center that I'm gonna be able to dismiss
as well because they're not about
there's not one thing that they're about
it's just oh they're both objecting to
these extremes yeah I hope to be the
glue because I also I also am such an
independent free thinker that I am
really I care a lot about trying to
bring people together across the
polarization that currently goes on and
I think that I think people like you too
can definitely help be that glue for
everyone to move forward in a in a more
both actualizing self actualizing way
but also collectively actualizing way if
that's what happens I mean I'm I'm I
only care about whether or not
something's true good and useful true
I'm not an useful I'm not that concerned
about bridging gaps between different
ideas because these two people could be
polar opposites and they could both be
wrong or one of them could be right but
the right could be in the middle it
could be the right could be anywhere and
they're correct because there could be
on the z-plane yeah we away from them
yeah oh my point isn't a bridge of build
a bridge between these two people or to
say that the truth is here and move them
both towards the center wherever the
truth is even if it's up there in the
loft I would like to move both of those
people as close to that as possible if
the true good useful thing is in the
loft and move them towards there totally
i but i have to do that yeah by moving
me there correct you have to move there
first and then
have that steel man reason discourse
with them not violence violence is dumb
in that case but I think a lot of the
reason why I'm calling it the glue
between them is because I think that a
lot of the true good useful things are
there and not in the loft but but there
there's definitely both Matt Dillahunty
wow that was that was such a pleasure
well thank you I had a good time any
other closing thoughts that you have no
so you are thought out at Matt
underscore Delahunty on Twitter we'll
put your link in the bio as well thanks
everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate it if you had a good time
please do share the content with other
people try and get the word out have
more of these conversations with others
and and build something from this as
well go write about it go create
something from it an audio podcast or
video podcast put it on YouTube try and
talk to other people about it and give
us a comment below with your thoughts
and join us subscribe and join us on
patreon so we can continue being
sustainable maybe we can come visit Matt
in Austin at some point and have another
sit-down with him that would be a lot of
fun if Matt will have us and last thing
is if you if you if you really this is
something that I've been trying to
hammer home a lot take this content and
build something with it don't just
consume it but build something with it
that's it thank you everyone for tuning
in thanks Matt for coming on the show I
greatly appreciate it alright everyone
peace